[Music] There are many things
in the nose that are poisonous.
Just like bird helmets and tsuji, the nectar is also poisonous.
But you didn't
know that. Just honey without poison
is good for demand.  I am sorry that the medicine I was giving the
baby was poisonous to the baby.No, Mr.
Add, please
rest your body and get well soon.Also, the
child of Ard is breathing.The
death he endured was a mystery to my father, who at that time regretted it.
Lumen was exiled due to her poor condition, including the way she was treated during childbirth.
Taso happened to learn of Ad's death, and
someone told her that honey was poisonous to babies.
He didn't want anyone to know that he was the one who
killed his only child.That's why the
person who wanted to get rid of him
is the main secret.In a
previous era,
Rish was attached to his older wife, Ard.  A
young girl who was separated from her parents, who cared for her,
and a woman who could no longer have children
may have developed a kind of relationship.  Fumi-sama
begins to chase Rihii back from the ball because he is informed that he was about to die after eating it.
Eventually, the leader takes control and Rihii is chased back.
Fumi-sama begins to bleed without knowing why.
However, the main cost, which was thought to never be seen
again, reappeared as a high-class
cost, and as the same senior cost, I was in a position to relegate the ard cost, and
the child and daughter brazenly asked for their mother over and
over again.
In order to protect Aadhi's position of not burying the child who is coming to see you, and to hide the sword of honey, you
put poison in the soup of the rishis.What do you
want?There is
nothing like that.
Yo